now that we know a little bit about how
to construct a unit normal vector at any
point in a curve that's what we did in
the last video i want to start exploring
an interesting expression so the
expression is
the line integral around a closed loop
and we're going to go in the positive
counterclockwise orientation
of
a vector field f dotted with the unit
normal vector at any point on that curve
d s
d s i'll write d s in magenta
d s so first let's conceptualize what
this is even saying and then let's
manipulate it a little bit to see if we
can come up with an interesting
conclusion we actually will manipulate
it we'll use green's theorem and we're
going to actually come up with the
two-dimensional version of the
divergence theorem which all sounds very
complicated but hopefully we can get a
little bit of an intuition for it as to
why it is actually a little bit of
common sense so first let's just think
about this so let me draw
let me draw a coordinate plane here
so
let me do it in white so this right over
here that's our y-axis
that over there is our x-axis let me
draw ourselves my curve
so my curve might look something like
i'll do it in i'll do it in a blue color
so my curve might look something like
this my contour and it's going in the
positive counterclockwise direction just
like that and now we have our vector
field and just remind we've seen this
multiple times i can my vector field
will associate a vector with any point
on the x y plane and it will it can be
defined as some function of x and y
actually i'll write i'll call that p
some function of x and y
times the i unit vector so it says what
the i component of the vector field is
for any x and y point and then what the
j component or what we multiply the j
component by or the vertical component y
for any x and y points so some function
of x and y times i plus some other
scalar function of x and y times j and
so if you give me any point there will
be an associated vector with it any
point there's an associated vector
depending on how we define this function
but this expression right over here
we're taking a line integral we care
specifically about the points along
along this curve along this contour
right over here and so let's think about
what this is actually what this piece
right over here is actually telling us
before we sum up all of these
infinitesimally small pieces so if we
just take f dot n so let's just think
about a point on this curve
so point on this curve maybe this point
right over here
so associated with that point there is a
vector that's what the vector field does
so f might look something like that
right over there so that might be f at
that point and then we're going to dot
it with the unit normal vector at that
point so the unit the normal unit normal
vector might look something
might look something like that that
would be n hat at that point this is the
vector field at that point when you take
the dot product you get a scalar
quantity you essentially just get a
number and you might remember it and
there's several videos where we go into
detail about this but that tells you how
much those two vectors go together it's
essentially if they're if they're
completely orthogonal to each other
you're going to get 0 and if you if they
go completely in the same direction it's
essentially just going to multiply their
magnitudes times each other and since
you have a unit you have a unit normal
vector here what this is essentially
going to give you
is the magnitude of the of the of the
vector field f that goes in the normal
direction
so think of it this way so let's think
about the the component of this that
goes in the normal direction it might
look something like that this would be
the component that goes in the
tangential direction so this expression
right over here is going to give us the
magnitude of this vector
let me write this down this right over
here is the magnitude
magnitude
of the component
component
of
f
of f
in
the
normal direction or in the same
direction as that unit normal vector
normal direction and then we're going to
multiply that times a very infinitely
small length of our contour of our curve
right around that point
so we're going to multiply that thing
times this right over here and so you
might say well you know okay i kind of
get what that is saying but how could
this ever be physically relevant or what
could be the intuition for what this is
this expression is even measuring and to
think about that i always visualize this
is in two dimensions you will later do
things like this in three dimensions
imagine this is a two-dimensional
universe and we're studying gases and so
you have all these gas particles in a
two-dimensional universe so they only
can have kind of an x and y-coordinate
and this vector field is essentially
telling you the velocity at any point
there so this is the velocity of the
particles at this point this is the
velocity of the particles at that point
that is the velocity of the particles at
that point and so when you take f right
on this curve that's the velocity of the
particles at that point they're going in
that direction when you dot it when you
dot it with n it tells you essentially
the speed going straight out at right at
that point and then when you multiply
that times ds you're essentially saying
what on any given moment how how fast or
at any given at that point right over
there on the curve how fast are the
particles exiting the curve and so if
you were to sum up all of them which is
essentially what this integral is doing
with this line integral it's essentially
saying how many how fast are the
particles exiting this contour are they
or even entering the contour if you get
a negative number or but since we're
taking the unit vector that goes the
unit normal vector that is outward
pointing it's saying how fast are they
exiting this thing if you got a negative
number that means there might be some
net entrance so this whole expression is
if you take that
that analogy it doesn't have to have
that physical representation
how how fast
fast are
particles are two-dimensional gas
particle
particles exiting
exiting
the contour and in the future we'll you
can do it in three dimensions where you
have a surface and you can say how fast
are things exiting that surface and so
let's start now that we have hopefully a
decent conceptual understanding of what
this could represent let's play around
with it a little bit especially because
we know how to define a normal vector so
let's rewrite it using what we know
about how to construct a normal vector
so if we rewrite it our integral becomes
this
we have our vector field f
vector field f dotted with the normal
vector the normal vector we can write
this way
a normal vector we saw was d y times i
minus d x times j and then we had to
divide it by its magnitude
in order to make it a unit normal vector
the magnitude was this right over here
dx squared plus d y squared which is the
same thing as ds which is the exact same
thing as the that little mini arc length
that infinitely small length of that of
our contour so we're going to divide it
by ds
we're going to divide it by ds and then
we're going to multiply it times ds
we're going to multiply it times ds and
ds is just a scalar quantity and so we
can actually even multiply this thing
times ds before taking the dot product
or vice versa but these two things are
going these two things are going to
cancel out and so we're essentially left
with f dot this thing right over here
but we have f defined right over here so
let's take the dot product so i'll just
write the integral the line integral
symbol again we're going in the
counterclockwise direction and when we
evaluate
and now let's in let me pick a color
that i have not used well i'm used to
many colors so i'll do yellow again so
now let's evaluate f dot this business
so dot product fairly straightforward
you take the the product of the of the
of the x components or essentially the
mag the scalar compo the the magnitude
of the x components so it's going to be
p x y p of x y times d y so it's going
to be p
of x
y
times d y
and then plus plus the product of this
of the magnitudes of the y component or
the j components so it's going to be
plus q of x y times minus
dx or times negative dx well that's
going to give us
negative
q of x y
negative q of x y
times dx so this is kind of an
interesting statement we've seen
something like not too different than
this before and when we saw even just
the definition of green theorem and let
me rewrite it here just so we remember
so the definition when we learned about
green's theorem it told us if we're
taking a line integral over this contour
and of and there's multiple ways to
write it but one way that we often see
it and we've exported already in in our
videos is if we were to say if we have m
of d
m times dx plus n
times d y this is equal to and i'm just
restating green's theorem right over
here this is equal to the double
integral over the region that's that
this this contour surrounds of and you
whatever whatever function you have here
times d y you take the partial of that
with respect to x
so you take the partial of this with
respect to x the partial of n
with respect to x and from that you
subtract whatever was on the dx side so
the partial of m with respect to y and
then time we could just say times d x d
y or you could say d a for e the
infinitely infinitesimally small little
chunk of area so i'll just write i'll i
could write d a let me write d a here
d
d all right dx
d y or it could be d y d x actually let
me just write d a here so since we're
speaking in generalizations where d a is
an infinitely small little chunk of area
so this right over here this is just a
restatement of green's theorem so we
already know this this is a restatement
of green's theorem and how can we apply
it here well it's the same thing we have
a little bit of sine differences but we
can apply green's theorem right over
here this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to the double
integral
the double integral over the region that
this contour surrounds and then we want
to do is we want to look at whatever is
the whatever is the function that's
being multiplied times the dy and in
this case this is the function that's
being multiplied times the dy and we
want to take the partial of that with
respect to x so we're going to take the
partial of p with respect to x
so the partial of p
with respect to x
and then from that we are going to
subtract we're going to subtract the
other function whatever is being
multiplied times dx we're going to take
the partial of that with respect to
y
so
here we're going to take the partial of
this whole thing with respect to y but
we have a negative out here so it's
going to be
minus partial
of q with respect to y
and then we have d a and obviously these
two negatives and subtracting a negative
just gives you a positive so then this
is going to be equal to the double
integral
over the region and maybe you might
already see where this is going maybe
getting a little bit excited the partial
of p with respect to x
plus the partial of q with respect to y
d a
now
okay oh yeah i took the partial of okay
what is this telling me cell well look
at this thing right over here p was
originally the the function that is
telling us kind of the magnitude in the
x direction q was telling us the
magnitude in the y direction we're
taking the partial of this with respect
to x we're taking the partial of this
with respect to y and we're summing them
this is essentially or this is exactly
the divergence of f and if you're
getting if that doesn't make any sense
go watch the video on divergence this
right over here
this right over here is the divergence
of f
this is the divergence by definition
really this is the divergence of our
vector field f and so we have a very
interesting thing this thing that we saw
this original expression that we started
studying which is essentially saying how
what's the speed at which the particles
are exiting this surface we now get it
in terms of this little expression and
we'll interpret it in an intuitive way
in about in a little bit of us in a
little in a little bit
so this is equal to the divergence of f
times d a over the whole region so the
double integral over so we're summing up
the divergences of f times the
infinitely small little chunk of area
and we're summing them up over the whole
region now why does that make intuitive
sense and for for you to realize why it
makes intuitive sense you just have to
remind yourself what the divergence is
divergence is a measure of how far of
whether things are expanding or
diverging or kind of contracting if if
you have a point over here if you have a
point over here where around that the
particles are kind of moving away from
each other you would have a positive
divergence here if you have a point
sometimes called a sink where the where
all of the particles are are kind of
condensing or converging you would have
a negative divergence here and now so
this should make a lot of sense you take
any little infinitely small area in this
you take little any infinitely small
area and then a right you multiply that
times the divergence there so the more
divergence here you're going to get a
larger number so and then you sum them
up across the entire region and so that
makes a lot of sense the more diverging
that's going on through your region
obviously the more stuff is going to be
exiting your your your boundary over
here so it actually makes complete sense
or hopefully it makes a little bit of
complete sense why the if you were to
see how fast are things exiting the
surface it's really the two-dimensional
flux how fast are things exiting the
surface that you take the sum over all
of them that's going to be the same
thing as summing all over all of the
divergences over this area that the
count that the contour is surrounding so
hopefully that makes a little bit of
sense to you and it was it's actually
another way of kind of thinking about
green's theorem and we also have just
explored what we've just said this this
expression that the divergence summed
over this region over here is the same
thing as the the f dot n over the
contour that essentially is the two
dimensional divergence theorem